Joey Lynn King was born on
July 30 1999 in Los Angeles.
She began acting
professionally
at the age of four,
appearing in a commercial
for Life cereal in 2003,
as well as ads
for Kay jewellers in 2007
and AT&T in 2009.
She even appeared
in a commercial for Eggos
in 2005,
proving she's not
the only Netflix star
with a taste
for frozen waffles.
In February 2006,
she made
her first TV appearance
in The Suite Life
of Zack & Cody
in which she appeared twice
as Emily Mason,
a young girl who Zac
and Cody have to look after
when they get roped into
running a day care centre.
Come on, horsey! Faster!
King's film debut
followed in 2007
in Reign Over Me,
in which she briefly
appeared as Gina,
the daughter of Adam
Sandler's character Charlie.
The same year,
she appeared in Entourage
episode "Gotcha!"
as the daughter of
UFC fighter Chuck Liddell,
as well as two episodes of
CSI:
Crime Scene Investigation,
including
"Woulda, Coulda, Shoulda",
where she plays the daughter
of a murdered woman
who holds the key
to the investigation.
In 2008,
she played the role
of Kelly Mackenzie
in the season four finale
of "Medium" Drowned World.
And she followed that
with the first of
many voice-over jobs,
playing the role of Katie,
an abnormal yellow yak
with frightening teeth,
in Horton Hears a Who!
In my world,
everyone's a pony
and they all eat rainbows
and poop butterflies.
In 2010,
she featured as Cassidy
in two episodes of
Ghost Whisperer
and landed her biggest role
to date the same year,
playing the lead in
Elizabeth Allen's 2010 film
Ramona and Beezus
alongside Selena Gomez.
It's picture perfect, right?
Let's be realistic, Ramona.
This is a curling iron,
not a magic wand.
King starred as Ramona,
an adventurous, imaginative
third grader
whose attempts to solve her
family and friends' problems
seem to backfire
spectacularly.
King also released a single
to accompany the movie
called "Ramona Blue".
Two more movies followed
in 2011.
She played
the role of Kirsten
in Jonathan Liebesman's
alien invasion sci-fi
Battle Los Angeles
and she featured as Molly
in Glenn Ficarra and John
Requa's romantic comedy
Crazy, Stupid, Love
as
Julianne Moore's daughter.
She even found time
to appear in the music video
for Taylor Swift's "Mean".
But all you are is mean
In 2012,
she landed her first
main role in a TV show
as Charlie in Bent,
an NBC sitcom
starring Amanda Peet,
and she also featured
as Brianna
in New Girl episode "Bully".
Your happiness seems like
a mask.
She got in her biggest film
to date the same year,
playing
a young Talia al Ghul
in Christopher Nolan's
third Batman film:
The Dark Knight Rises.
2013 turned out to be
an especially busy
cinematic year for King.
She played Christine Perron
in James Wan's
The Conjuring,
one of five daughters
assailed
by supernatural forces
in a sinister
Rhode Island farmhouse.
Another voice role followed
in Sam Raimi's
Oz the Great and Powerful,
in which she played
the role of a living doll
called China Girl.
In 2014,
King had a recurring role
as Greta Grimly,
the daughter of troubled
Duluth police deputy Gus
in critically acclaimed
crime drama Fargo.
And she also had a role
in Zach Braff's
Wish I Was Here,
a comedy drama
in which she plays Grace,
the 12-year-old daughter
of Aidan and Sarah Bloom.
More horror lurked
in the shadows
with 2018's Slender Man,
a Sylvain White film
based on
the viral creepy pasta story
from the Something Awful
internet forum.
King played the lead role
of Wren,
a Massachusetts girl
who makes the mistake of
summoning
the eponymous monster.
A more cerebral
psychological horror role
followed in Veena Sud's
The Lie,
a remake of 2015
German film We Monsters.
King co-stars
as Kayla Logan,
a girl who finds herself
trapped in a chilling lie
when her parents try to
cover up a fatal accident.
King made
her Netflix debut in 2018
with The Kissing Booth.
King stars as Elle Evans,
a positive, quirky teenager
whose budding romance
with bad boy Noah
puts her lifelong friendship
with his younger brother Lee
in peril.
It's one of the most
re-watched films on Netflix,
with one in three viewers
diving back
in for another helping,
and it also bagged King
a Favourite Actress
Kids' Choice Award
for her portrayal of Elle.
Oh no!
King landed
two more TV roles in 2019.
She appeared in three
episodes of Life In Pieces
as Morgan, a pregnant
17 year old from Modesto,
which also features
her older sister Hunter.
And then she starred in
award-winning
true crime drama The Act,
based on the real-life case
of Gypsy Rose Blanchard.
King plays Gypsy,
a chronically ill girl
whose relationship with
her over-protective mother
takes a dark turn
when she learns
her illness was fabricated:
a case of fictitious
disorder imposed on another
or, as it's more
commonly known,
Munchausen's syndrome
by proxy.
It was a critically
acclaimed performance
and King was nominated
for an Emmy, Critics Choice
and Golden Globe.
2020 brought us a second
Kissing Booth movie
in which King reprised
her role as Elle,
and a third
and final instalment
of the film trilogy
is available to watch
on Netflix now.
Do you have a favourite
Joey King performance?
How many times did you
re-watch The Kissing Booth?
Let us know in the comments
and remember to subscribe to
the channel for more videos
about your favourite stars,
shows and movies.